Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday!
Happy 2017!
Today's video is like Voldemort's soul: It comes to you in eight parts,
one of which is inconveniently located inside our protagonist.
Part One: My Snot.
Hank, there is so much snot inside of my body right now,
so I apologize if I sound sick. It's because I am sick.
Part Two: Speaking of my health, 100 Days has begun!
My best friend, Chris, and I are trying to have a healthy midlife crisis,
so over the next one hundred days,
we're gonna learn a lot about health and fitness,
and over at youtube.com/100days, you can see me do this,
and also this sweet move,
and also quite a lot of this.
Mostly that, really.
Doing partner abs always reminds me that
my stomach was made for resting a laptop upon.
But my life is changing pretty dramatically during these one hundred days.
You can also follow along with us if you're so inclined,
and if you're at NerdCon: Nerdfighteria next month in Boston,
you can do a live workout with Chris and me and our trainer, Laura.
Part Three: Ten Year Anniversary.
Hank, ten years and one day ago,
I uploaded my first ever video to YouTube.
In honor of that anniversary,
here's a terrible, old school Vlogbrothers jump cut.
If I ever find out I only have one day to live,
I want it to be a day full of 2007 Vlogbrothers jump cuts.
Anyway, that first video began-
...I'm not going to be good at this.
I wasn't good at it, of course,
and in many ways, I'm still not.
But I feel so lucky to be at it ten years later,
and I just wanna say
thank you to everyone who's been part of the last decade with us.
Part Four:
So a while back we asked a Montana-based artist,
named Claire Emery
to make some limited edition woodblock prints
to celebrate vlogbrothers' tenth anniversary.
Claire is just an amazing artist,
and she created three prints to celebrate a decade of Nerdfighteria.
Each of them is available for pre-order now at dftba.com
in black and white or hand-colored.
We're not getting a royalty or anything on this.
We just love these prints
and wanna celebrate this anniversary.
So I hope you like them.
Also, Michael Aranda made a beautiful video about Claire
and her work,
which you can watch over at Hank's channel
Link in the dooblydoo.
Part Five:
Speaking of celebrating, throughout 2017,
Hank and I are going back to watch
every single Vlogbrothers video
for a new project called
"This Date in Vlogbrothers' History"
For instance, on January 3rd, 2007
Hank referenced for the first time
that people were saying we looked like The Proclaimers.
And on January 3rd, 2011,
I made one of my most viewed videos ever,
which I'm sure had nothing to do with the thumbnail.
You can watch the videos and read our reflections on them
over at the Community tab
at youtube.com/vlogbrothers/community.
Or you can get notifications
by making sure you're subscribed—
there is a little button directly beneath the video—
and then clicking the bell to get notifications on.
Part Six:
Hank, as you may have heard,
Nerdfighteria sponsors a third tier English soccer team
called AFC Wimbledon.
And this Saturday
at 10 a.m. Eastern time, here in the U.S.,
AFC Wimbledon will play in the third round of the FA Cup
against Sutton United,
a game that will be televised on proper American cable television!
Specifically the channel Fox Sports 1.
Wimbledon players wear DFTBA on the back of their shorts,
and you can see those shorts
live in high definition this Saturday!
A group of Colorado Nerdfighters will be watching the game
at the Three Lions Pub in Denver,
and there may also be other places to watch the game
live with fellow Nerdfighters.
I've started a Reddit thread on the topic.
Link in the dooblydoo.
Part Seven:
Punishments.
Hank, in your final video of 2016,
you went over four minutes
in a non-educational video,
which means, for the first time in several years,
we've got a vlogbrothers punishment comin'!
Your punishment will take place live on stage at NerdCon: Nerdfighteria.
I'm pretty excited about this!
Nerdfighters, if you have suggestions for Hank's punishment,
please leave them in comments.
Part Eight:
A moment of sentimentality.
Hank, getting to make stuff with you and Nerdfighteria over the last ten years and three days
has been the great professional privilege of my life.
When we started this project,
we weren't particularly close.
Like, I left for boarding school when you were eleven,
so, I never really knew you as anything other than a kid.
I mean, before Vlogbrothers,
we talked on the phone maybe once a year?
Now it's at least twice a week.
These past ten years,
Nerdfighteria and its projects have brought so much joy and fulfillment to my life,
but the best of it, for me,
has been getting closer to you,
and being part of the awesome that you bring into the world.
Thank you.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.